a quantum computer is a device a
technological device that in principle
would harness the full capacity of
quantum mechanics to undertake
calculations that a standard computer
would be absolutely unable to achieve
one way of thinking about is this
there's an approach to quantum mechanics
where one imagines that there are many
in some sense parallel realities moving
along in some larger environment if you
will where for instance if I want to
measure an electron quantum theory says
well there's a 50% chance it's there and
a 50% chance it's over there
and what does that mean well one
interpretation says well there's
actually two universes and in one
University electron is here and in
another universe it is over there it's
kind of a crazy sounding idea but a
quantum computer perhaps can harness
that by doing some calculations over
here and other calculations over there
in parallel now it's doing in some times
twice as many calculations as a
classical computer existing in one world
would be able to do now imagine taking
that idea and spreading it over all of
the possible realities allowed by
quantum mechanics now you're harnessing
all of these different worlds if you
will
to do all of these calculations in
parallel much faster much more powerful
doing calculations that in a single
universe would be impossible so this is
one way of thinking about it and it
offers amazing possibilities and we just
need to see how successful we are at
harnessing these ideas to actually put
it into practice and that we don't know
yet we'll see going forward but it's an
exciting possibility
you